once you've determined nature right
you've got your other secondary what are
you do next I'm just giving you the next
task while I make a bit more space what
do you do after you've determined what's
what I'm going to do some more
substitution of one and three I've
already substituted into the second
derivative to determine nature but then
where else do I substitute it into very
good back into this original function
which I have not finished rewriting why
am i doing that because I need
coordinates I need to know where this
thing is okay so go ahead and pop it
back into this guy just needed to write
it over here so I had more space and I'm
give me the coordinates of those turning
points please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're just something in research - is
it these that you're subbing in what
what are you substituting in see these
numbers
what are they signify again the six in
the minus six what do I see if I I'm
gonna see a shift nine clear all three
go ahead AC
I I don't know how to get rid of half of
things but I'm just like nuclear option
just wipe it off okay are you talking
about their coordinates which ones which
say okay so I wonder where you're up to
already you can see from determining the
nature with a second derivative I've got
something to help me out so these are
the values I got can I get some
confirmation by the way when you
substitute in the original function okay
yeah you're happy okay fantastic
getting lots of nods that's really good
so what do i do at this point well what
I've got here what this pair of lines
off the top tells me is coordinates of
turning points that's one comma zero and
we said that's a maximum and then you've
got three comma negative four which we
said was a minimum which is kind of like
oh that makes sense
the minimum is below the maximum zero is
higher negative four is lower okay but
remember I said to you one of the
situations here is that we have these
constraints right we have a domain
restriction which means we've also got
it include what's going on here in two
ways number one our our stationary
points within this domain have a look
our X values because this is a domain
restriction so two x values exercise a
one and three are they are they within
this range they are answers they are the
first stationary what is just within it
but it is okay so number one as you can
see over here sometimes you will find a
stationary point and you're like are but
sorry your domain restriction means
forget that stationary point ever exists
because it's not included okay but in
this case they're both okay but the
other issue is these are the two points
here like I've drawn here may actually
be higher or lower than what you found
on these two values I actually don't rub
off that zero okay so what we're going
to do is just like we found where our
minimum turning point and our maximum
turning point are we also need to find
where these endpoints are so I'm going
to ask you to write after this we're
going to test endpoints okay so just
like we took the X values of the
stationary points I'm going to take the
X values of my endpoints right this F of
1/2 I'm gonna go ahead and evaluate that
and then I'm gonna do F of 5 as well
right so just like I tested my
stationary points I'm gonna test my
endpoints on the original function okay
yeah the endpoints of the domain okay so
let me say that again right and it's
probably worth writing this down okay
the domain restriction affects you in
two ways right you have to consider
number one are my turning points within
this domain okay ah turning points
within domain because sometimes they're
not turning points right that's the
first thing and then secondly you have
to actually check the values you get at
those endpoints you've got a sub in a
half into your original function
this guy and you've got a sub in five
okay your other one check values at
endpoints
now I've just been saying all this to
stall for time to see if anyone's
actually gone to the calculator a half I
don't expect you actually do that by
hand
has anyone got the first one Matt you on
yeah
negative 0.875 yeah that sounds like um
what's that that's like negative 7/8 or
something okay
and then what do we get for our other
sixteen did you say sixteen okay
fantastic so what have I got here I'm
looking for a maximum and I'm looking
for a minimum now I know it's either
gonna happen at these turning points or
it's gonna happen at the ends so let's
do it one step at a time
minimum of these four values which one's
the lowest one negative four is the
lowest which is our minimum turning
point that we found before so I'm gonna
put a big box around that and I'm gonna
say this is not just a minimum this is
the minimum now we've got that sounds
very informal so we actually have proper
language for this you can call this the
global or the absolute you'll see both
of those words used at different times
and they mean the same thing right
it's like the the minimum for everywhere
that I can consider right so this is the
global or absolute minimum
okay what about a maximum of those 4
values 1 2 3 4 it's 16 isn't it let me
get another color yeah so this is the
global or the absolute maximum right and
you can see it doesn't happen at a
turning point right so global / by the
way um because we have this language for
saying when it's the minimum like
everywhere and we also have it for when
it's just our in this little
neighborhood right this guy up here F of
1 equals zero we said hey that's a
maximum we would call that a relative
maximum or or a local maximum it's just
in this little area it's the top part
but if you look broader if you're
willing to look globally then you can
find other parts that are higher so am i
shut that down up the top here for you
so this guy up here is the local or
relative
Maxon yeah
in this case if it were if this were
like you know me trying to sell stuff
then five dollars in this situation
would be myself walking like whoa this
clearly it's like wow this is just like
a break-even situation or whatever
happened to me okay all right
so let me just rewind right you get
constraints in these max min situations
because we're not just like a function
that can just exist wherever it likes
right there are certain yeah
restrictions on it right yeah yeah as an
example right it's like you're only
allowed within this domain and that
might be yeah maybe it'll be between $1
and $3 or something like that and so
you'd check $1 and you check $3 okay so
can I ask you if you've got your laptop
they're actually in this tool this will
answer right can you go ahead and pop
this into your into desmos right get a
graph of this okay and then when you're
when you put that into desmos put this
in right it'll give you the whole curve
with no restrictions so it'll go down to
negative infinity it'll go off to
positive infinity but what I want you to
do is on the same line that you put the
equation I want you to go ahead and put
this domain restriction with some curly
braces around it because what that will
do is tell desmos to restrict the domain
of your function and then you'll see
what's going on so go ahead and do that
so this there's the function okay not
bad all right well well done okay so you
can see predictably you've got this
waving around of the cubic function
right but importantly because you've
restricted within a certain domain right
you're like oh on the left hand side
there a half okay you get this value
here but it's not as low as the global
minimum in this domain because you can
see if the stationary points like way
lower okay that's the negative for value
that you got there but then when you
have a look at the maximum that you
found the best turning point maximum if
you're like oh excuse me even though
it's the highest spot in that little
neighborhood it's the highest spot
locally you can go way higher because of
how far the domain goes to the right
hand side does that make sense
it just completely runs a
any questions on that so make sense